i'm going to be interviewing the people  of london how they feel about this sign  abortion is a cop-out  hi guys public interviews what's your  opinion  what's that crazy full conversation  i'm not allowed i shouldn't have an  opinion i don't think you're brainwashed  and this is your opinion which means  it's false it's actually offending many  people  i was like what is on there like it's  ironic that they're taking away choice  it's crazy  that's our opinion you're hypocritical  well we don't talk about exceptions  we're talking about the rule okay you  don't think your daughters you would  rather teach them to be careful with who  they sleep with  but i'm not judging anybody